do you know of a place I can use the
bathroom then like where's a good public
bathroom here over 40 million people
visit Los Angeles every year now that is
a lot of butts I'm here in Hollywood to
find out what makes a good public
bathroom and what makes one safe enough
to poop in is there any way to make a
public bathroom feel safe enough to poop
in No
how do you decide which business to
choose I mean I think a department store
is always a safe bet from the look of
the building you can see if the
bathrooms clean or not so if you think
the facade of the building is sexy the
bathroom is good I've come to Hollywood
I go clubbing so I'll just use the
bathroom at the club Oh Hollywood I
don't think has a great bathroom game
but I'm gonna try to find the one good
bathroom that we gotta have somewhere
okay we're in the car right now on our
way to our first stop and I realized
that I'm actually starting to have to
poop like for reals this is the exact
scenario I was fearing for all of our
tourists and now here I am experiencing
it myself we got to find a restaurant we
got to find a department store and I
just got to find a normal public
restroom so we're in this small ah level
3 and level 2 side to level 2 are we
moving says we're on to where we on to
already well how do I get out we were
already on the second floor oops I'll
take care of it from here BAM
it's back as you crowded this is never
gonna work if we're going to the third
floor there were just so many people
there how could that have been a clean
bathroom well maybe it was though maybe
that's why I was so popular there looks
good
there's pee on the seat I can't sit down
on that my legs will get wet with urine
let's keep looking
okay so one of our rules was to find a
place with a beautiful exterior so I
thought maybe this Victoria's Secret I'm
gonna see if they have a bathroom just
that they could take it let me use
here's one have bathrooms here to you
others are public bathrooms you know
that are there any like secret nicer
bathrooms around here no no nice
bathrooms here well no that's good to
know
my sipper is down oops we are at a
preposterous ly crowded Starbucks and
I'm gonna see if I can possibly use
their bathroom high drive to buy
anything to use the bathroom don't need
to buy anything we're good it's a public
bathroom look at this look at this clean
back there's only one speck a little
paper lots toilet paper around seat
covers available clean see I can't poop
here
such a lot of ladies in line and a
gender-neutral bathroom I can't do that
to them cannot leave them with the pool
bathroom it was a really nice bathroom
like and this is in the center of
Hollywood there must be dozens of people
using this bathroom all the time so
props is Starbucks for having like
actually the cleanest bathroom I've
encountered but wait
that's another public restroom maybe
they can redeem themselves don't pee on
the seat stop peeing on the seat there's
pee on the seat let's try to have in
Buster's it's like a department store
for fun like there's so much fun right
good
do you guys have a bathroom I could use
this place is incredible
okay this is pretty good there's poop on
the floor but it's the whole roll it's
clean
there is Twitter bigger here
so as he covers this is a pretty good
bathroom and they don't have spent any
money playing games all I want to
we did it find a place to poop and now
guys let's play some video games okay
let's play some video games let's get
the BuzzFeed card and get ourselves some
fun at David Buster's I used $25 a
BuzzFeed's money to get two shot glasses
and Laffy Taffy rover i think today has
been a good day